what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday february 8th the joint is
brought to you by
[__] draftkings how good was
that super bowl
you didn't have you have to bet a game
or a side
you could have took a prop bet like the
first touch the first quarterback to
score a touchdown
the first running back the first
interception
that's what draftkings is all about it's
[__] fun
football's over but draftking is back
with the new crazy promotion that starts
today
monday and it only gets better wait till
you hear this one
it's called hammer the over starting
right now
today lower the over and under on
sunday night's la versus denver
game by betting the over are you
listening to me
this is the [__] this is only the
mind of draftkings
hammer the over so starting right now
everybody who
bets on sunday nights
lowering the over under on sunday nights
l.a denver
for every thousand people that bet the
over the
over under drops by one point are you
understanding me
so if you got to get your brother your
[__] cousin your third grade teacher
your priest all in on this you get it
down to [__] zero
the best part is that even if the line
lowers
the odds remain at even money are you
[__] crazy
that's draftkings that's right by
hammering the over
you can double your [__] money hold
the line [__] up there's jumping now
and let's hammer the over into
submission
and if that's not enough for you
remember the weekend starts [__]
saturday
with ufc 258 usman versus that [__]
brazilian savage
and they got great odds and promotions
all week long this week
on basketball college basketball hockey
draftkings is safe secure and
[__] reliable
and you get your gears when you want it
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app
right now use promo code joey when you
sign up
for ham of the over on sunday night's
game between la and denver for every
thousand people that bet the over in
sunday's game
the line will decrease by one
point this is for a limited time only
right now download the draftking sports
book app
use promo code joey thank you now here's
the legal mumbo jumbo i got to say
you got to be 21 over new jersey
indiana michigan virginia only
restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook
for details now if you got a gambling
problem you got to take care of it you
got to call 1-800
gambler or an indiana 1-809 with it
or in virginia 888-532-3500
but if everything's [__] kum see kum
sa
let's do this [__] download the [__]
app
let's hammer the over and let's win some
[__] guitars next weekend
the joint is also brought to you by zip
recruiter
right now home is a lot more than a
place to hang out
you're [__] working from your home
everybody is everybody gets up
brushes their teeth put some powder on
their [__] [__]
you know combs their hair puts mascara
on
doesn't even [__] put pants on and
you go downstairs so if you own your own
business
home is also where you got to hire new
employees
and that's where zip recruiter comes in
zip recruiter makes hiring
faster and easier because you can do it
all from one convenient place
hello right there ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter does all the work so
do me a favor right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey this whether your business is huge
or you have four or five employees zip
recruiter can help
they can bring you the most qualified
recruit to you
no problems no dilemmas and
if you [__] even check into them
they'll get you the qualified candidate
within one day
that's what i'm talking about so go to
ziprecruiter.com
joey and you're gonna try it for free
just by going
to ziprecruiter.com joey
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire the joint is also brought to you by
holy [__] my favorite bluetooth
listen football season may be over but
you could still run
deep into your ladies little [__] end
zone you understand me
right or wrong just because of these
little [__] jumping up and down with
their little jerseys on
[__] them there's a guy somewhere having
an orgy
with three little midgets and a tall
shake anyway blue chews got these three
tablets
to help men achieve harder and stronger
erections
even if you're young even if your
erection is [__]
you know tremendous why [__] around you
want to get you want to show up with the
tank
the lure and they're the first chewable
dick pill
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis
at a fraction of the cost and this isn't
the [__] you know
the monkey dust your buddy got from a
trip to [__] mexico
this is science blue chew is an online
prescription service
no visits to the doctors no awkward
conversions
no awkward conversations
and no waiting online at the pharmacy
you sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
physicians and once you're approved
you receive the prescription days it
doesn't come in a bag with a big dick on
it
so you don't have to be ashamed it ships
right to your door
in a discrete package and your mailman
won't even know
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy all right
listen i got a special deal for you it's
[__] monday how are you how am i
gonna show up on a monday we'll have
something for you
i'm gonna let you try blue chew for free
when you use promo code joey at checkout
that's five dollars for shipping but
you're gonna get it for free
that's bluechew.com use promo code joey
to receive your first month free
[__] free all you do is pay for
shipping
and there's also as always i want to
thank bluechu
for sponsoring the joint with that let's
get this [__] party started
there's a little packet of blue chew
right there you put in your pocket
you take it out when you're ready to get
a little piece
you eat that and within minutes you're
[__] staring at a pole
let's get this party started
hey look who it is welcome to uncle
joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 8th of [__] february it's a
beautiful day to be alive
welcome to uncle joey's joint again i'm
here on a monday
with my light little blue sweatshirt on
listen i like blue
on a monday morning a little light blue
it starts to weak off right
lets you know i'm non-threatening you
know what i'm saying it's just
a cute little color you know what i'm
saying just to start the week off on the
right [__] leg here
if not you know you it's funny i told
you guys that when i used to go to
for commercials if i would wear a black
shirt to a mobster commercial
i wouldn't get it but if i'd wear a
white shirt
to a mobster commercial i'd get it
if i did it for a movie it was vice
versa
so if i went for a mobster roll in a
movie
i would use a black shirt if i go for a
mobster movie
and a commercial i would wear a white
shirt so just
it's like a joke it's not what you say
it's how you say it so
sometimes for me colors it just i don't
know i just wanted to [__] talk about
the color blue
i had a great weekend this weekend uh
the super bowl was great
uh [__] saturday one of my friends
called me up
and he uh asked me if i wanted to go to
another
friend of mine's house that just had
surgeries having [__] surgery that's
my age
it's funny because when i got there
there was four of us it was my friend
his wife and the guy who drove me
we've been hanging out together since we
were
maybe 13 years old i remember her
going to take me to get my driver's
license
paperwork before i had a connection
and my buddy didn't even need to get me
a driver's license she just called the
driving school
but she was the one that took me when i
was 16 and a half
to get my permit that's how back i go
with these people you know
so i guess he broke his toe so he's got
like a boudon like my wife
so we just went down there yesterday and
ate a few brownies and talk [__] it
you know and this is what i got home my
wife was like how was it and i was like
you know
i had forgotten about this i had
forgotten what it was to sit with
friends and just talk
everything for the last 20 years
especially my life in l.a
has been business and this is what this
move was about
people for me this move wasn't about a
career move
if i wanted a career i was going to stay
in la
uh you know i i don't know right now as
of march what is it february 8th
right now i don't know what's going to
happen with stand-up i know that i have
that weekend on my birthday at vinnie's
i got the 24th
i got the whole month of march i'm doing
a uh you know
residency there but after that i really
don't know i've been doing comedy
now this month right now
was when i started at wits end 30 years
ago
you know this is 30 years i've been
doing this so i don't want you going
spreading rumors that i'm quitting i'm
not quitting i'm not quitting to stand
up i just don't know how
or how i want to do it you know i might
just do it as a hobby
i might just stay in new jersey i might
just stay on the
east coast who knows maybe in september
my mind will change remember when the
movie comes out
my mind will change completely but as of
right now i don't even see me getting on
a plane man
it's the weirdest [__] thing like i
just i talked to theo
you know i had a nice talk with theo and
dale's like
dawg i'm not even looking at anything
until 2022 i was like jesus christ
i thought i was [__] bad you know
it's just
you know and he said he goes i'm tired
we've been burnt out you know i go back
with theo
i didn't know theo at the time but i
remember playing beaumont texas
which is on the louisiana border pretty
close i
you know check me maybe an hour i think
i don't know and i remember playing
beaumont and hearing about theo
and beaumont was slayed slade hammond's
rooms
shout out to slate hand down in houston
uh
he had the room out in beaumont and i
would
hear about theo theo was kicking ass
down in new orleans as a young kid
so the other night when i was talking to
theo theo's like dog i'm [__] tired i
was like god damn
i thought i was the only one he's he
said he was looking
to buy a house in nashville he likes it
and uh
that yeah he's not looking to do
anything you know and we're all the same
i mean we're all doing spots
he goes to the monday night zany's right
at nashville
and they give him a wednesday a month
and you know we're still in it like that
but
to be back in the impact of that of how
big that was at the time i don't think i
could do it anymore
it's not that i don't want to do it you
know i love you [__] you know i
love performing i just
i don't even see myself doing a 10 30
show
like that's how far away my mind is like
i was like
what if i got to do two shows and one
night i gotta work my comedy cardio
again
yeah it's been a february 29th
was my last road gig february 29th
remember last year was a [__] leap
year
so don't say joey there's no february
29th
there was a [__] leap year i was in
vegas that was
my schedule last year consisted of
atlanta
one night two shows valentine's day and
[__]
uh tempe and then vegas
i did three weekends on the road last
year
and you know i always worked out i don't
feel confident when i go on stage now
guys
i'm doing that birthday weekend and the
tickets are 25 bucks because they have
to but i feel kind of weird
i'm not up the [__] par i will be by
that night you know once i touch the
stage
[__] happens i start talking i get a
joint in me
you know we start [__] around but
no i i'm not i'm not a fan of the comic
i was if you want me to be on
at least i feel that if you guys feel
something different then you know i
appreciate it but
i don't feel i'm a third of the comic i
was i'm still clunky
even in my writing i write every [__]
day and especially
the last three weeks i have written more
i have thought of more [__] stories
by the way i called my buddy mike
roebuck we had a great talk in colorado
and we were talking about all those
times and i met mike
in 85
and we're gonna do a zoom in a couple of
weeks
he's just trying to get his kid back in
school and stuff in colorado
because his wife is a teacher we got on
the phone and i mike robert was one of
those kids i told you about that was my
friends in aspen with carl
and vince hall when carl punched a guy
in the head and the piece of meat flew
out of his head and all this [__]
me and mike were on the phone the other
day telling stories
i had a f i almost bent over i almost
had to take a pain pull i was laughing
so [__] hard
just about things that we were doing up
in colorado as kids and [__] like that
but to get back to the original
conversation i don't even know how i got
on mike robot
to get back on the original conversation
that's been the first time i've been
with four friends
i mean joe really i've known joe rail
his father turned me on to marble bread
bobby bender i [__] his parents took
me in when my mother died
didi cardinelli i knew her and her
sister the mother fay
listen to this the mother fae was the
first milf
that i ever hit on that was the first
that was my first me too attack
back in 1979. she's like mercy's
grandmother now
mercy loves faye
loves faye every time i go over it i
feel so bad because i tried to make a
move on faye when i was 15.
when i was 16 i tried to make a move on
faye
and she still remembers and we still
talk about it we still giggle about
but now she's an old woman it's crazy
how i go over there my daughter
and my daughter disappears with faye
they just sit on the couch
they watch cartoons my daughter explains
the cartoons to faye
faye [__] loves it it's it's just a
different world guys
so my wife asked me would you you know
what you guys talk about what you do i
said you know
we just drank water we smoked a half a
number you know
[__] like that but i go terry it was
just
the point of being with three people
that i grew up with
you guys know i could have moved to
austin i could have just called joe in
one minute
and i missed joe i miss joe with all my
heart i miss red band you know how much
i love those guys but
i wanted to be home it was i had done my
time
i had done my i had done for everything
i had to do in la
and right now i mean if there's nights i
sit here going yeah i'm gonna do comedy
i don't know what extent i'm gonna do it
to or whatever i was telling them
yesterday at the table
and i said it i said i'd rather walk out
on my feet
than crawling on my knees what does that
mean
that after a year or two and not doing
stand-up
i start going on stage and booking these
[__] rooms and these agents are
pushing
you gotta charge 55 and you're like guys
i'm not worth 55 [__] dollars
you know i don't want to have to go on
stage and have to room walk out because
i just don't have it anymore
and that's what i feel sometimes i feel
like my comedy window came and went i
swear to god i feel this
i swear to [__] god it's just if it's
like anything
anderson silva was a [__] great
fighter
one day he broke his leg and he can't
stop [__] losing
you know and some people stay around too
long
and then you got to crawl out i don't
want a dog i'm not known for [__]
crawling out on my knees so i'm not
going to do it now i like walking out of
things
i like walking away from things on my
[__] terms
like the church like joey karate i do
[__] like that all the time i've been
doing that since i'm a kid
like cocaine once it's over it's [__]
over
that's it there's no going back there's
no revisiting
there's no let's try it one more time
for old times sake
it's over it's over that's it because if
not you'll be [__] haunted for the
rest of your [__] life you know
so it was just nice just to go down
there i got to sit in the front seat
finally i could sit in the front seat
i'd have to sit in the back of my leg
propped up
people [__] looking at me like i'm
driving miss daisy
my wife is driving me around a subaru
and i'm sitting in the back seat
with my leg up it feels like my groin's
gonna pull i'm good we made it it's been
a month it's
today's a month since the [__]
uh surgery how do i look people
do i look like the pills got to me was
there a big [__] kahoot
no cbd lying came through ice came
through
and the pain pills were the last things
i thought about and i did this out of
respect for you guys
just to show you i'm sick and tired of
hearing [__] excuses in life
well i had surgery and i got hooked you
have an option
you have an option you know what last
night was the first night i slept in the
bed last night
when i woke up this morning i had a pain
in my
[__] shin that because i didn't know
i didn't know what was going on because
i had knee surgery
and then tom segura called me one night
while he was doing physical therapy
with his physical therapist and we were
talking and she was asking me about what
i thought like oh my [__] leg is
killing me
but it's not really my knee it's my shin
and she goes do you know why you
shouldn't
because they had to cut it and pound a
new knee into it and told me all this
[__]
just her telling me this [__] gave me
nausea i'm like i can't i can't even
hear it no more but even this morning i
woke up because i slept on the bed
my shin was on fire i came down i drank
my little yoga probiotic
i drank my [__] coffee i had
breakfast i put ice on my leg
i popped two [__] high-level tylenols
and i got tons of pain pills
i'm just playing the hand i can't wait
to go back into his office next monday
and go
here's your pain pills back and he's
going to go what you didn't
you know i got pissed off at them
because they tell you to take two
every four hours but they give you eight
so wait a second it's two every four
hours
so there's 24 hours in a [__] day
right
so there's two every two every four
[__] hours so what's that
like [__] eight a day or something i
think it's when you feel
pain yes you know whatever he but they
gave me like 13 of them
that's what i got every time i went
there 13
11 17. you can't even start a party with
this
i was gonna do like an oxy edible party
i can't even throw a party
you know i thought that the pain was
first of all i thought it was gonna be
like any other surgery
it's painful for two days after that you
get rid of the [__] pills you don't
need them
i really that's but there's only one
surgery that i [__] ate every pill
from and i [__]
suffered for that for a long time my
shoulder surgery
i ate every [__] viking and that
[__]
and i'll tell you what guys a week later
for the first time in my life
i was thinking some creepy [__]
things when you read a whole
prescription of viking and you start
stinking some creepy [__] things
and don't think that like the second or
third day of these pain pills
i just have creepy things going into my
mind because i [__] did
and that's why i worked that cbd lion
like a [__]
you could take these and now if i need
to take them i'll take them for
physical therapy this last week i've
only taken physical therapy
that's it after physical therapy and i
take
one little one and that's it i don't
take two
i'm trying to get the [__] off these i'm
trying to sweat this [__] out of my
system
i've been doing club bats lately dog you
know me dog i don't [__] around guys
i try my hardest i don't just i just
listen
i don't want to just talk to talk for
you guys i want to walk the walk
so you guys could learn i can learn
something we could all learn something
together
i don't do this i do this podcast we
could all learn something together
i learned from you and you learn from me
and we learn from each other
and we take care of each other i make
you laugh you guys make me giggle with
messages from time to time
so it all works out you know
sorry i had a little cotton mouth there
for a second i had a [__]
drenched uh whatever but the topic i
wanted to talk about this week
was something that i didn't have that i
wasn't good at god either gives you this
what doesn't give you this this is a i
think it's a talent
i think what i'm about to talk about is
a talent that
you're going to end up getting you're
going to end up really
being good at it if you want to get
anywhere in life
but if you don't have it you're going to
have a tough [__] time in life
and that's patience and i'm not talking
about the song from guns and roses
i'm talking about life's patient there
was nobody
more impatient than me in this life
i was the most impatient person and what
i've been reading lately
in the emails from people on patreon
you know on facebook you know people
send me emails from time to time joey
i'm getting into stand up joey i'm
getting into this
but the thing i read the most the the
emotion
that i get the most from
65 of the emails that i
read and this this is a lot it's not a
desperation emotion
you know what emotion i get
impatient everybody wants something
quick we all do dog that's why they
invented the lottery
that's why they invented the lottery but
you know what this you know what the
chances that you hitting the lottery are
they're [__] hard but there's people
who are very impatient
i was and it's weird because i had to
think about this
i thought back to my youth how patient i
was
when i used to build models i used to
build models when i didn't know the
language too good
i used to build models that's what my
thing was building models every day
in the summer i built a new model i was
good at it planes ships
walls hoax you know spider-man's the
whole [__] thing
i did it with glue you know the [__]
paint glue whatever the [__] snort
and glue
i did that [__] and then somewhere along
the line i don't know what happened
somewhere along the line we all you know
i was i was
i was patient to play with g.i joes and
[__] like that
but i nev i never had the patience to
play poker
never had the patience to play monopoly
never had the patience to for any of
that [__] you know
so i i didn't look at it as a problem
i didn't look at anything at all i just
thought that
i just didn't like something you know
when uh
you know you buy a car or whatever
you buy a car you buy a car and you
you're broke you have to do the work on
it yourself
you don't know what the [__] you're
doing you know you have no idea what
you're doing
and you and all of a sudden you call
mike and i go mike i gotta change the o
and mike's like
well uh my brother could do it for you
but you have to wait till tomorrow and
i'm like i can't wait till tomorrow i'm
gonna have to do it
and then you end up doing it and you go
to [__] loosen the thing underneath
and you use the wrong uh
wrench but the the
the ratchet whatever the [__] you use
the ratchet set
and the [__] thing gets stuck or you
strip the [__] nut
and now it's a complete different stuff
that's because you were impatient
if you were patient you would have
waited for mike's brother i'm just using
this
as an example but patience is the reason
why half of us
don't have careers about that
think about that half of the people
that listen to this podcast half of the
people that are walking around
don't have a career that they want to
because of patience think about it
me my first choice was to be a guitar
player
but what do you got to do you got to
learn how to play the guitar
you got to practice you got to put a
band together
you got to make an album you got to get
signed
you got to put the album out then people
got to listen to the album that's a lot
of steps i ain't got that type of
patience
you know what i'm saying that's a lot of
[__] right there
that's you know what i'll let somebody
else do that
so then your mind starts launching what
else can i do oh
well i want to be an attorney oh okay
here we go again
you got to go to school every day you
got to get a's and b's
then you got to get into a decent school
and get a's and b's and then you got to
go to a law school
which is another [__] three years
i'm not doing that think about it think
about how many
[__] think about look
look i'm 58 years old i could have been
[__] retired
20 years already
have you ever thought about that
i could have been retired already
getting a pension full
[__] medical benefits i mean if i get
a [__] hangnail
i'm the first in line and i made the
biggest mistake in my life
not joining the service how can you not
join the service
are you [__] stupid it's 20 years
it's tough for two years it's really
tough for like a year you got to do
jumping jacks the basic training
and they spit on you and call you a
piece of [__] you've seen all the movies
but once you get stationed and stuff
you know if you're single if you play it
right and you keep your mind right and
you're single
and you do the first 10 years then
eventually you meet a woman and you
settle down and you buy a house you can
live on base
you could save [__] millions and then
you come out of the service
if you join the service when you're 38
if you join when you're 18 what's 20
years
30 [__] eight
now you come out 38 with a pension
and you can do whatever the [__] you
want so you
your pensions got to be huge especially
if you retire as an officer
think about it think about all the [__]
we passed on
because the patient's getting in the
[__] way
because i did it for years with a book
now
look it took a while it took a while but
now i'm cooking with [__] gas
now i'm cooking with gas i've written
two chapters i just don't know where to
put them
but i've written two chapters you
understand me
i just don't know where to put them and
i haven't sent them to the agent yet
because i want to
write one more to make it complete but
i'm right and that's all that [__]
matters
but we don't have the patience to do
anything
like i didn't you know when i went to be
a [__] electrician
yeah you're an electrician you could
work but you're an apprentice
what does that mean apprentice means
you're not gonna make no money
you know it's right that's another thing
anytime you go to get a job
it's always well for the first five
years you make
you barely eat and then we start paying
you 80
000 a year and you're like so i gotta
wait five
[__] years [__] that patience
if you really wanted to do that you go
you know what
i'm moving with my mother i'll
rent a car i'll do this you do
everything you do
to figure it out to do that but half the
things i haven't done in my life
it's not because i was lazy or it's not
because i was stupid
it's because i just didn't have the
[__] patience and that's just
[__]
and i'll tell you i read your patreon
guys
i read your facebooks i read your tweets
you know i read your messages you guys
know i answered messages back
even on patreon they said if you don't
pay the five dollars you don't get your
messages answered
i answer your messages you know if you
ask me i'll answer your questions back
especially the legit [__] question or
legit
problem and that's the number one thing
i run into
is people think that they you know some
kid wrote media
i swear to god i've done three open mic
sets what's next
what's next you know what next is
do number four and then do 500
do a set every day for five years
then call me
then call me that's the best thing i
could do for you
people are that impact and i didn't see
because i'll tell you what guys i'm
gonna be as honest i can which i always
am on this [__] show especially with
my comedy
when i got to l.a
i was impatient for about
90 days
that's the square business i was
impatient for about 90 days i had
already gotten into the store
so that took a lot of that that calmed
me down a little bit
but it was my mentor at the time a great
man rest in peace his name is rick
dukeman
he was in groundhog day he played he's
the chubby guy in
groundhog day he did a bunch of bruce
willis movies just a great guy
and i remember we were talking about
something
we're talking about something he said to
me listen to me and listen to me
straight
these things you're doing because i
would call them up getting all excited
like when i got to la
i booked the pilot and then i think it
was
after i shot the pilot i called him up
and i must have been tuned or [__] up
or something
and he told me he's like listen man
because i was in a rush you know like i
i was there and i was making things
happen
you know listen mitzi
did and didn't do me any favors by
making me a regular right away
okay looking at it in hindsight
uh she did it was great
i i belonged to be a regular all that
stuff
but by her making me a regular
it also made me want other things
that i wasn't prepared to get
that and that's what happens to a lot of
us that's what every comic goes through
that
that just didn't happen to me you know i
still remember the first time
i was in a room in denver colorado i had
come back from
jersey he was 93. you know when i was
doing
i was starting to rock and roll what's
rock and roll
i could do 20 minutes and have a good
time you know
i'm starting to rock and roll and
[__]
one night i'm up on stage
and usually when it's you know in a
comics world
before i go on stage mike is the host
he'll come up to me
and he'll go you're doing 15 minutes
when do you want to light and i'll go
give me a light at 10
and if he gives me a lot of 10 in my
head i can measure
five minutes you know what i'm saying
like i know more or less what five
minutes is
on this particular night i i didn't see
a [__] light i didn't see a [__]
sign
you know people were laughing people
were having a good time
then i started to slow down a little bit
you know
i didn't know what was happening and
then finally i see the kid and he weighs
me
and i get off the stage and people clap
i did okay
you know and he came back to me and i
don't know if it was
i did 34 minutes or if i did 43 minutes
again i i don't know i don't remember
was a long time ago but i
did a lot more than what i [__]
thought oh my god you should have seen
me on the way home
oh my god i was saying [__] to my who i
was making a list of my head
of the people i was going to call the
next day i'm calling this studio
i'm calling warner brothers i mean i had
done like 34 or 43.
it was one of those two jimmy bader was
the host i just talked to jimmy two days
ago too
he's from 20 years i still talked to the
guy that helped me
with comedy and denver the most jimmy of
beta he said he called me the other
night to tell me
he was with some girl and the girl knew
i don't [__] know
but jimmy bailey gets off but jimmy
betty comes up like jimmy where the [__]
you been
he goes i went out to the car to have
sex with some girl i'm sorry
i go i'm up here 34 or 40 try i didn't
know because you know he told me
you did [__] 34 minutes or 43 minutes
listen
when you've been doing 10-minute spots
for [__] four years
and all of a sudden somebody comes and
says to you the 34
jesus christ is your ego get big for the
first time in my life i thought i was
[__] don rickles
i went home i couldn't [__] sleep i
had a
because i i told you you got to get a
book called
stand-up comedy by judy brown jude
isn't judy brown yeah had judy something
judy carter
it's stand-up comedy by judy do you have
it yeah i heard you talk about it
well it had the back the back ten pages
has everything you'll need it has every
number every comedy club
every number the bookers big the big
agencies the people who book ships
i think she used to have it in the old
edition
and i guys i still remember waking up
the next morning
i'm like calling like i don't know who
it was
i wish i could tell you i don't know who
it was i'm like going i'm joe diaz
i did 43 minutes last night and they
hung up on me
you know they were like what the [__]
but
that you know you're so [__]
impatient
we can't wait to get to where we're
going
and we don't and that's when i gotta
tell you something that's what happened
the last [__] 10 years to me
you know i wasn't it wasn't that i was
impatient the last 10 years
it was that things were moving so fast
i wasn't having time to enjoy them
has that ever happened to you where
things are going so fast
that you don't even have a time to
[__] enjoy them
like i sold out two shows at the new
york [__] theater
i didn't even have a chance to celebrate
it
like things were moving so fast i
couldn't even understand
like i sold out this theater usually you
take like a month off and you celebrate
you have a great time and
but life was moving so fast that i
wasn't even appreciating the things i
was doing
you know and this is why i hate
like if you're gonna get into comedy if
you're gonna get into any career
and you want it to work for you patience
has to be the number one priority on it
we talk a lot about goals we talk a lot
about journaling
we talk a lot about getting our [__]
hands dirty and you know
rolling up your sleeves the one thing we
don't talk about enough
is patience because without patience
you won't hang in the [__] game you
will not hang in the [__] game and
it's sad
and if it was nobody else who had a
heart
nobody had it harder than me when it
came to patience
because i just wanted it so bad the way
we all
we all want something so bad we
but we see ourselves there we don't this
is why when i pay to do your goals i
want you to write them
so you're not there i want you to see
all the dots that you have to connect to
get to that place
the impatience is that we just see that
that's all we see we see a comedy store
blow jobs a [__] tesla rosa
[__] that's all you see i'm gonna
have a big bank account
i'm gonna have a maid i'm gonna have a
butler that's all you see
you know i'm gonna have a big electrical
company i'm gonna have the biggest
fishing company in the world i'm gonna
have the best restaurant in the world
but you never get to that because you
didn't have the patience you don't have
the patience to stick it out
you got to have the patience to stick it
out that's why i love
those [__] stories about the busboy
who bought the restaurant you know i
love
those stories about the kid who went
there to change
tires and now he owns the [__] gas
station
i love all those type of stories i love
my story
i love my story i love that i love it
that i was down and out
i love it that i was down and out and
then i was even more down and out
and then guess what and then on top of
being down on that i went to [__]
prison
i [__] loved it and then i got a
[__] prison
and i got married and i got beat up by
that too because i couldn't cover the
spread because i was a [__] loser
and then without even [__] knowing
you know i tried everything
i was smart enough to [__] do
anything i wanted to do i really was
i was a [__] roofing estimator i
turned myself
into a roofing estimator who the [__]
it becomes a roofing estimator with a
[__] ged
i did i didn't know what the [__] i was
doing how the [__] do you even
end up a roofing estimator i love my
[__] story
and then i said [__] all this [__] this
is [__] this work [__]
i'm gonna try my hand at something that
is [__] the hardest thing in the
world
because i don't give a [__] about me i
got no wife
i got no kid i got nothing i i had a
wife and a kid but they didn't [__]
like me
so what's the [__] difference you
know everything i touched was [__]
what are my chances of being a stand-up
and being successful
[__] zilch so let's [__] go for it
let's prove myself the [__] wrong and
man let me tell you something
it was the first time my life that i
showed patience
because i don't even know i don't even
know where the patience came from
i don't know if it was homegrown i just
knew myself
for me to succeed in this [__]
business
i gotta slow it down a notch you know i
always have myself
i have my daily goals my weekly goals
and i have my six month goal
you know in la i was i was always in la
leaving in six months i still remember
shooting basketball and [__]
torturing them like when am i going to
shoot
like i didn't know the movie business i
had no idea what the movie business was
i didn't know it was hurry up and wait
you know that's what the movie business
is hurry up and wait
the first movie you shoot you're either
gonna like it or you're not gonna like
it because
you might sit there for 13 hours and
they might come get you on the 13th hour
and say
come and say your line you know what you
feel like after 13 hours
you feel like you've been raped 13
[__] times
now you want me to go say my [__]
line i've been sitting in a [__] room
watching nature shows because you only
got three [__] channels on your
[__] cable system
in the [__] trailer and now you want
me to come and tell the [__] line you
[__]
are you [__] crazy but that's what it
is
and if you don't have that [__]
patience you know how many great [__]
comics i bumped into over the years
that if they would have had the patience
they would have been bigger than
chappelle
what do you think i don't know i met
tons of funny people out there
i met a guy one time in connecticut that
i could not even look at he had me
[__] rolling so hard
his [__] jokes and i would call him
from time to time to check up on him
but he had no patience he didn't want to
do what i was doing he didn't want to go
through the system
he didn't wanna he wanted to be a
[__] headliner
and anybody who got in his way was a
[__] [__] oh he's an [__]
he's an [__] he's everybody was a
[__] [__]
except for him don't be that person
don't be that person
everything has its own time progression
you know you start off as a [__]
truckloader
and you become a [__] truck driver i
don't know i don't even know if it works
that way
i'm just saying to you that if it wasn't
for patients i wouldn't be here
and i was the most impatient
[__] there ever was
and i want to thank god that he gave me
patience
and i'm taking this time to tell you
guys on this podcast
that if you want to have a career in
something
your patience has to be top [__]
notch
because if not it's like you know how
many people
i talk to guys i'm embarrassed to say
this to you [__]
do you know how many people i've talked
to
that i've said to them hey man you don't
do your podcast no more
and then like it didn't get me anything
uh i i didn't i didn't become a star
do you think i did the podcast to become
a star
i did the podcast just to get it was
just another form of art
it was just another art form if i could
do this for an hour i could talk on
stage for an hour
it's all it's all mixing in together
that you know when you move to l.a
people come to him like oh if you do
movies and commercials
you're not a real comic you're a [__]
[__]
you're a [__] [__] for even saying
that
i know that bill hicks was pissed at jay
leno for [__]
you know doing the doritos commercials
and all that [__]
but let me tell you something it all
goes hand in hand
and you want me to tell you what the
worst thing is guys i'm good at all of
them
you see me on big city greens that's a
voice right
i do voice-overs i act i do stand-up
i write you've seen me on tv you see me
in commercials
i do them all because they all go hand
in [__] hand
they all go hand in hand and it's like
my friend rick dukeman said to me
that you know
okay for example mike
goes on stage tonight and he gets a
standing ovation
let's say he goes to philadelphia to the
parks casino
and he gets a standing ovation tonight
boat shows
and wednesday he goes for a movie
right and this happens
and he doesn't get the movie and he's
calling me on the way back
in his car i'm his best friend so he's
venting to me
he said can you [__] believe i just
got two standing ovations at parks
and i didn't get this shitty park in the
[__] this shitty part
in a [__] movie you know like
that's what happens
everything you do that's a positive
even though you don't think
it's making a difference
it's making a difference it's spinning
okay i did analyze
that the second one
nobody saw the movie the movie ate a bag
of dog [__]
it happens what do you want me to do
jump off a building
you win some you lose some i want to
make your name
yeah i did uh
you know analyze that
i did a bunch of these little movies
taxi i got one line in
spider-man 2 i got
one line in rodney dangerfield back by
midnight
i got a couple days on that you know
they weren't making any sense to me so i
called up rick dukeman and i go rick
the pilot this i'm killing at the store
you know all this [__] and nothing is
happening for me
and he says that this all comes together
in
cultures this all grows in cultures
he goes one day this is all gonna weave
together you're gonna do something
that's gonna weave this together
and then it becomes something and i'm
like what the [__] is this guy talking
about
you know i'm not a smart guy what the
[__] are you talking about
sure enough i got the longest yard
you know law and order sbu
[__] uh
my name is earl and then the writer
strike came
2000 you know 2007 i quit coke
i did my last episode for my name is
earl
december 2007 the writer strike came
2008.
uh they picked it up after a while i
don't think i booked anything on 2008
i have to check 2009
i got married i was doing some stand-up
i was i wasn't back at the store i was
doing stand-up with joe
just joe and i was doing some weekends
of my own
i bumped into billy gardelle before he
got
the first show on cbs and i remember
that he was having a hard time
with the funny bones something the funny
bones made him an offer
and now i was going through the same
thing
i'll never forget that they called me
one day and they said we have a bunch of
rooms for you but you have to do sunday
through thursday
and i was like okay you know i don't
want to do them or whatever
so with what a lot of you people really
don't know is that i got out of con like
i was like
i'm done with comedy i'm quit i'm gonna
wait until um
you know i'm gonna wait until joe takes
me on the road
and then with movies and tv i'm just
gonna wait till my friends call me and
offer me roles or you know i had a lot
of casting people that knew me
that would just call me up and go joe
you want to read for this i think you'd
do a good job on this i was really lucky
in that form so
i said that's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna quit comedy i was gonna get a job
you know selling cars or whatever just
stay at home with my wife
i i didn't see my career growing you
know i had already been in it uh
20 years i was coming up on 20 years
and but i remember one day
being in the main room and paul
rodriguez is up on stage
laying it out just destroying it
just destroying the [__] room and i
walked in from the back and i
it was like a dead night i didn't think
and mitchy had her own booth
and as i walked past it i hear fat baby
and i
go [__] and then she was you know mitchy
was tiny
so she was about if she was in the booth
with people you could see she was in the
booth
but if she was in the booth by herself
you couldn't really see she was tiny so
i just heard fat baby and i went over
and sat next to her
and i'm sitting there watching her poor
rodriguez kill
and i remember looking at her and she
looked at me and she goes
wait till you get to 20 years
and i was like 20 years [__]
i don't think i'll do comedy 20 years
you know i don't think at that time i
was probably doing comedy
maybe 10 years maybe 12 years 11 years
around there
and she goes once you hit the 20 year
mark
things are really gonna change for you
and all this [__]
well i started a podcast
and what rick dukeman told me
and what all the mentors i had told me
was right
at the 20-year mark at the what just
at a certain point let's not even say
the 20-year mark why did i even say that
i'm sorry
at a certain point so once the podcast
came
and not when i was doing the podcast
with felicia but at one point with the
church
and through joe rogan that
whole thing that whole blanket got put
together
now people were hitting me up going we
didn't know that was you
in spider-man 2. we didn't know
that was you in the longest yard we
didn't know
that was you when the meatball king we
you know
we didn't know that was you you know
it's so weird
that now people watch that and they'll
hook me up immediately we didn't know
that you were mafia three we didn't know
that you it becomes a big
[__] now i got this resume and
everybody knows what the resume is you
just look at it
and it's right there but if i would have
told you
that i was going to have this resume 15
years ago
because i didn't have the [__]
patience patience
patience is just as [__] important
as the effort you're putting in because
if you're not
patient you're gonna lose your mind and
guess what
i saw more [__] good comics leave la
because they were impatient didn't stay
i'm lucky that somewhere along the line
i found the patience and i saw the light
if not i would have been one of those
statistics
don't let patience ruin your dream
whatever dream you have don't let
patience
ruin your dream you know how i let
patients come into my life
by knowing i was doing my job
you won't have paid when do you have
patience when you're not doing your job
when you're just playing three chords
every day and telling your friends i
can't wait to have my band
you know that's when you're impatient
when you're not doing your job
but when you're doing everything you can
to be that person your impatience will
go away
you'll get patience because you know
you're moving in the right direction
but joey how do i know i'm moving in the
right direction
you'll know it when you're doing it
do you think i knew what i was doing
when i walked into the store when i met
joe
and no i had a job to do my job was to
write comedy
perform comedy and get on stage as much
as i could
that's my job point-blank range not
[__] getting in people's business
not being an advocate not being a
political comic none of that [__]
my job what's that thing what's that
movie she made
eat pray love go [__] yourself get on
stage
write your jokes and [__] uh rehearse
or whatever the [__]
i said earlier get on stage right and
do as many [__] sets as you can and
know that you're gonna [__] is
you only get impatient if you're not
doing the job
you'll get patience if you're doing
everything you can to attain that goal
so sometimes we don't we work too much
on the goals
sometimes we work too much on the
writing let's start working on the
patients from now on
patience is the big [__] motivator
because without patience you're never
gonna get to that [__] dream
and that's the monday morning podcast on
february 8th
a beautiful podcast on [__] patience
it's a beautiful day to be alive
so i figured i'd say this today because
we've been talking a lot about karma
and all that [__] all this snow has
making me think of
making me think a lot about colorado
which is good because it's helping me
writing
in the book but when i was looking at
the book the other day i was like jesus
christ
i can't believe that a month ago when i
started talking about this on the
podcast with these guys
i swear to god guys i must have had a
hundred pages on the computer
and i erased them all
erased them all erased them
erased them i didn't want him around no
more i didn't want to read that [__] no
more i didn't want to look at it no more
i was starting from [__] scratch i
erased the [__]
the the [__] x
outline i had i did it all i got rid of
everything and i started from scratch so
thanks to you guys for giving me this
opportunity
but today i said i just want to talk
about patience because i don't think we
talk about it enough
and i don't think people have enough and
i think people don't give themselves
enough patience to get to where they
need to be
and they quit and they forget about
everything i'm just really happy
that somewhere along the line patience
came into my life
and i held it out and now i got the
option to either
keep doing what i'm doing at 30 years or
move on to the next thing
like i said i don't know how i feel
right now
i feel like comedy just might be a hobby
for the rest of my life just
pick a club do a couple nights a month
but you never know something might
[__]
spike me up the ass and i'm back on the
road doing weeks
it's not going to be anytime soon but
it'll be in time
and i'll let time figure it out we still
got the summer
but uh all i know for now is february
19th and 20th
uncle vinnie's comedy club thank you
very much for listening to the podcast
today
it's a [__] snowy [__] week here
in jersey
we got about six inches yesterday so
uh me and mike had to work hard last
night to put this together
for a monday morning i love you
[__] thank you very much for
always uh
watching this oh i want to thank sure
for sending us our beautiful new
microphone
i told you [__] i didn't want
to start the podcast in a way
in october because i wasn't ready but i
had no choice i had to be ready
i forced myself to do this every week
even though it wasn't going to be the
same podcast
even though a lot of you wasn't going to
be happy that's not my problem
my problem is that i had to be happy and
i had to keep pushing forward
the only situation we had was because of
the pandemic
we couldn't get a lot of things that we
wanted so a lot of people got pissed off
well you said you were gonna use a bar
i'm getting rid of that boy i told you
that right yeah we're getting rid of
that ball that's it yeah we're getting
rid of that bob because
we don't drink we don't really drink
it's
i was gonna do a podcast at the bar i'm
gonna stock a bar
and then after living down here for
three weeks with the [__] up leg i
realized that
it's a [__] clunk i could take that
out of there and put like a microwave
and a counter
and you know make him well that's gonna
be a [__] family room anyway you know
like i said to you in the beginning this
was all temporary
and we also got a picture of the
legendary
chance dragon [__] in
so you can't talk [__] now no more we
got everything covered we got chance
we got ac dc we got sister heisted we
got charles bronson
we got sydney moncrief but who gives a
[__] so i want to thank sure
for sending us the microphone mike was
also getting us some new cameras
they finally [__] came so we could
finally add some dimension to this
like i said to your people patience
patience [__] people wrote me letters
hate mail
complaints to me you know about this the
iphone
guys it wasn't all gonna happen over
[__] night i thought i could make it
happen
but once i got here i mean dawg it took
six months to get the compressor
the compressor's not coming until
february 19th
i mean everything [__] takes time so
thank you for
if you stuck around to the bob la
lingas's
all you patreon [__] thank you
for the support and the love
you know you guys expected something
that i couldn't deliver but
i also told you to stick it out with me
that every week we would get stronger
and we would get [__] better and we
would keep adding things
and before you know it a couple more
weeks once this [__] is over we'll get a
new [__] studio somewhere
you know we're going to move on with it
onwards so this was just the beginning
this is just to show you
that we don't just [__] talk to talk
we walk the walk
it's all about patience have a great
[__] week [__]
i hope you enjoyed the podcast today
stay black
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening on a monday i know you're busy
you got your own lives you got [__] to
do and people to see but before we leave
i want to talk to you about a few
companies here that i love and i do
business with and they're tremendous
i mean the joint is brought to you by
today by blue chew
like i said in the beginning football
season's over but you could still run
deep into your [__] girlfriends or
wife's end zone
blue chews got these tablets to help men
achieve
harder and stronger erections i'm an old
man
i get like a [__] three-quarter woody
i need this stuff
you understand me and it works and it's
good sometimes i do the ad
and i don't have them here why do you
think because i [__] need them i got
to give my wife a stabbing from time to
time too
and i want to show up with everything i
got you know what i'm saying i can't
show up with a three-quarter inch
[__]
anyway and they're the first chewable
dick pill
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis at a fraction of the cost
listen this ain't one of those [__]
things they sell at the [__] liquor
store
or the [__] you know monkey powder
that your friend brought you from brazil
blue chew is an online prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward com conversations and no
waiting online at the pharmacy
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription within days it's that
easy
it's that easy and it ships right to
your door
in a discreet package nobody knows it's
not going to be a picture of a naked
lady
nothing like that not even the mailman
or no
you know nobody needs to know your
business bluetooth tablets
are made in the usa and they prepare and
ship direct it's cheaper than any
pharmacy you're gonna use
so this is what i'm gonna do for you
today i got a special deal for you
you're gonna try blue chew for free
julia what the [__] are you talking
about
free use promo code joy once you go to
bluetooth.com
and at checkout just pay five dollars
for shipping
bluechu will send you a little package
promo code joey and you're gonna get
your first month
for free okay that's how you start a
[__] monday off
i'm showing up with something i'm
showing up with love i'm giving you some
gratitude
even if it is to get your dick hud i'm
giving you something
who else is giving you pills to get your
dick card nobody so uncle joey's here
to help you out go to bluetooth.com
right now and press in joey at checkout
and just pay five dollars for shipping
and i'm gonna send you a free month
supply
of [__] blue chew the joint is also
brought to you by come on now
draftkings just cause the super bowl is
over [__] draftkings is just getting
[__] started
this is why i love this time of the year
because people like well football's over
well let me tell you something
you still got pro basketball college
basketball
[__] march madness baseball
hockey you got more [__] going on than
you even know what to do with
and at draftkings they got you covered a
casino
poker baccarat i mean come on
what the [__] and now they got a new
thing hamilty over
starting right now today that's why
right after this you're going to go to
draftkings sportsbook app and download
it right now after this
because starting today they got a new
thing called lowering the
over under and it's based on sunday
night's game
between la and denver the game
by betting the over so for every
thousand people that bet the over
are you with me the over drops by one
point
so i don't get like i don't give a [__]
if you gotta get your brother
your [__] cousin your third grade
teacher
the [__] priest you gotta get all
your friends in on this
and you can get it down to zero the best
part is
that even if the line lowers the odds
remain
at the even money are you [__]
kidding me
or what why are you even here download
the draftking sportsbook app now
that's right by hammering the over you
could double your [__] money
hold the line [__] jump in now
and let's hammer the over
into submission and that's not even
enough remember
that saturday we got a huge title fight
happening
it's ufc 258 usman against that [__]
brazilian that's a [__]
beast i think that'll push it back
because the kid had covered before
but i don't give a [__] forget covert
this is about making money today
it starts today i guarantee you you got
a tremendous
basketball game on tonight or two it
starts today
there's got to be some college action
but when you sign
up for draftking sports book right now
you sign up for hamilty over
for the sunday night game between la and
denver for every thousand people that
bet the over
the line will decrease by one [__]
point
this is your chance to improve the odds
of hitting
so tell your friends your family this is
a [__] team
effort this is your chance to improve
the odds
of hit of the over hitting so [__]
get in on it what the [__] are you
waiting for
listening that's promo code joey for a
limited time
only at draftkings sportsbook and here's
the legal [__] part i gotta tell you
you gotta be 21 or older new jersey
indiana
michigan virginia only restrictions
apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a
gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler or an indiana 1-809
with it
or in virginia 888 532-35 [__]
hundred but first
download the draftkings and hammer the
odds
hamilty over with code joey
the joint is also brought to you by one
of my favorites because people love this
zip recruiter listen home is a lot more
than a place to hang your hat
a lot of people are working from home
and if you own your own business home is
also where you got to hire new employees
and there's and there's a way that you
can hire the best employees out there
and that's zip recruiter that's where
they come in zip recruiter makes hiring
faster
and easier because you can do it all
from one
convenient place ziprecruiter.com
joey ziprecruiter does the work for you
their matching technology scans
thousands of resumes
and only sends you the most qualified
people for your job
not these momos that can't even spell
you check them out and if you like them
you invite them to apply for your job
it only takes one click that's it then
zip recruiter sends
them an email from you and bam you stand
out from the competition you see what
i'm talking about
it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
[__] day
you know this is about time time is
money
zip recruit is the way to go and right
now you can try ziprecruiter for free
free free free
free you can get ziprecruiter for free
dot com slash joey that's
ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free just by going to
joey it's the smartest way to hire i
want to thank zip recruiter
i want to thank draftkings the best
and i want to thank bluetooth for
helping us out today on a monday and for
coming into your life
and for sponsoring the show but most
importantly i want to thank you guys for
listening on a monday morning
and doing whatever the [__] you need to
do and supporting the podcast i love you
[__]
have a great week we will see you
wednesday
tip top magoo ready to [__] go
shoot that poison arrow through my heart
shoot that poison arrow there you go
[__] i love you
[Music]
so
you